There's certain conversations that those of us who do not live on farms get into with people who do live on farms, where you know, you just know. As the city person, or the suburban homeowner, you know that the farm person you're talking to is just thinking the entire time you're talking to them, "You are so naive." A lot of these conversations have to do with animals and their deaths.
那些不住在农场的人和住在农场的人之间，会有一些对话，你就是会明白。作为城里人或郊区的房主，你和农场的人交谈时，你清楚地知道对方一直在想：“你真是太天真了。”这些对话中有很多都与动物及其死亡有关。
Take this example. The woman who runs the website for our radio show, Elizabeth Meister, was at the annual exhibition run by the American Poultry Association in Columbus, Ohio. And here she is. She's standing in a room with 12,000 chickens. And she gets into this conversation with an 11-year-old girl.
举个例子。我们广播节目的网站管理员伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）在俄亥俄州哥伦布市参加了美国禽业协会举办的年度展览。她当时就在那儿。她站在一个有12000只鸡的房间里，和一个11岁的小女孩聊了起来。
I've only been in poultry and waterfowl for a year. I'm more into waterfowl.
我养家禽和水禽才一年。我更喜欢水禽。
This is Kamiko Overs from Bliss, New York, who was at the convention to show some of her own birds.
这是来自纽约布利斯（Bliss）的卡米科·奥弗斯（Kamiko Overs），她来参加展览是为了展示她自己养的一些鸟。
So do your friends think it's weird? Do they think it's strange that you show chickens and stuff?
那么，你的朋友们觉得这很奇怪吗？他们觉得你展示鸡之类的东西很奇怪吗？
No, because a lot of people show. They'll either be showing pigs, or cows, or rabbits, or something like that. A lot of people in our school show different things.
不会，因为很多人都参加展示。他们有的展示猪，有的展示牛，有的展示兔子，或者其他类似的东西。我们学校里很多人都会展示不同的东西。
Kamiko and Elizabeth talked for a while. And then Elizabeth tried, very, very gently, to ask a question that was on her mind.
卡米科和伊丽莎白聊了一会儿。然后，伊丽莎白非常、非常温和地试着问了一个她一直想问的问题。
Do you-- this is sort of a hard question for me to ask. But do you ever eat them?
你——对我来说，这个问题有点难开口。但你吃过它们吗？
Yeah, I do.
吃过，我吃。
You do. And does it make you really sad when-- do you raise these chickens from little chicks?
你吃过。那么，当你……你这些鸡是从小鸡养起的吗？这会让你感到很难过吗？
Yeah, we hatch them out. And then, yep. We get them right from the hen. And we eat them a lot. We do raise a lot for eating.
是的，我们孵化它们。然后，是的。我们直接从母鸡那里得到它们。我们经常吃鸡肉。我们确实养了很多鸡来吃。
And so when you're cooking up this chicken that you've raised from being a little chick, do you feel a little bit guilty that you're eating this chicken?
那么，当你烹饪这些你从小养到大的鸡时，你会因为吃掉这只鸡而感到内疚吗？
No.
不会。
No?
不会？
No.
不会。
Do you ever eat the chickens that you show?
你吃过你展示的那些鸡吗？
If they're no good for show, the losers, yeah.
如果它们不适合参加展示，就是那些被淘汰的，会吃。
Kamiko is untroubled by this. If a bird has bad feathers or a lopsided comb, it might be a nice bird. But it's not going to win competitions. You eat it. That's life.
卡米科对此毫不介意。如果一只鸟羽毛长得不好或者鸡冠歪斜，它可能是一只不错的鸟，但它赢不了比赛。那就吃了它。这就是生活。
Those of us who do not live on farms, we divide animals off into those we love and those we eat. In Kamiko's world, there's not such a hard line separating the two. You can get to know a bird on an up-close and one-to-one basis and still eat it. An animal's transition from buddy to dinner is a great deal less problematic than it is for us city folks.
我们这些不住在农场的人，把动物分为我们爱的和我们吃的。在卡米科的世界里，这两者之间没有那么明确的界限。你可以近距离地、一对一地了解一只鸟，同时依然可以吃掉它。动物从伙伴变成晚餐的过程，对她来说比对我们城里人要简单得多。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And every year, during the period between Thanksgiving and Christmas, the highest poultry consumption time of the year in these United States, we bring you a program about poultry, our annual Poultry Slam, stories of chickens, turkeys, ducks, birds of all kinds, and our relationships with them.
从WBEZ芝加哥电台和国际公共广播电台（PRI）播出，这是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每年在感恩节和圣诞节之间——这是美国一年中禽类消费量最高的时期——我们都会为您带来一档关于家禽的节目，即我们一年一度的“禽类大乱斗”（Poultry Slam），讲述关于鸡、火鸡、鸭子和各种鸟类的故事，以及我们与它们之间的关系。
In past years, we have brought you an opera about the life of Chicken Little. We've brought you the story of a hand puppet duck that would not leave people's lives. And naturally, we've brought you real stories of actually growing up with turkeys, and chickens, and other birds. And in putting together this year's show, a very few particular ideas and questions kept coming up in story after story. Without us ever intending for it to happen this way, a lot of this year's show has turned into a kind of referendum about where you draw that line between friend and food.
在过去几年里，我们为您带来过关于“小鸡快跑”（Chicken Little）生活的歌剧。我们带来过关于一个死缠烂打的手偶鸭子的故事。当然，我们也带来了与火鸡、鸡和其他鸟类一起成长的真实故事。在策划今年的节目时，在接二连三的故事中，几个特定的想法和问题不断涌现。我们从未打算让节目变成这样，但今年大部分的节目内容已经演变成了一种关于“在朋友和食物之间划定界限”的公民投票。
Act One of today's program, Still Life with Chicken. Food writer Jonathan Gold tells what it's like to pan-fry a chicken with a live chicken watching you the entire time. Act Two, Last Meal. When Francois Mitterand knew he was about to die, he decided that the last food to cross his lips would be poultry, a tiny bird that is actually illegal to eat in France, a bird that, by tradition, is eaten with a napkin covering your head. Michael Paterniti set out for France to try the contraband capon himself. He has a full report.
今天节目的第一幕，《静物与鸡》（Still Life with Chicken）。美食作家乔纳森·戈尔德（Jonathan Gold）讲述了在一只活鸡全程注视下煎鸡肉是什么感觉。第二幕，《最后的晚餐》（Last Meal）。弗朗索瓦·密特朗（Francois Mitterrand）知道自己时日无多时，决定他最后吃下肚的食物必须是禽类——一种在法国实际上属于违禁食用的小鸟，一种传统上必须蒙着餐巾头才能吃掉的鸟。迈克尔·帕特尼蒂（Michael Paterniti）前往法国亲自尝试了这种违禁的阉鸡。他带来了完整的报道。
Act Three, People who Love Chickens and Hate This American Life. Last year, a woman named Karen Davis started a national letter-writing campaign to try to get This American Life to stop the very program you're listening to at this very moment, the annual Poultry Slam. In this portion of our show, she explains what it is that we just do not understand about poultry, and why the whole idea of this poultry show was wrongheaded from the start. Act Four, The Meaning of a Bird. David Rakoff explains how his life was changed in a single evening in a room of 5,000 chickens. Stay with us.
第三幕，《爱鸡之人与讨厌〈美国生活〉的人》。去年，一位名叫卡伦·戴维斯（Karen Davis）的女士发起了一场全国性的写信运动，试图让《美国生活》停止播出你现在正在收听的这个节目——年度“禽类大乱斗”。在节目的这一部分，她解释了我们对家禽到底有什么误解，以及为什么举办这种家禽秀的想法从一开始就是错误的。第四幕，《鸟的意义》（The Meaning of a Bird）。大卫·拉科夫（David Rakoff）讲述了他的生活是如何在一个拥有5000只鸡的房间里度过一晚后发生改变的。请继续收听。
Act One, Still Life with Chicken. It was an accident that Jonathan ended up living with the chicken. He was not living the kind of lifestyle that one usually associates with chicken.
第一幕，《静物与鸡》。乔纳森最后和这只鸡住在一起纯属意外。他当时的生活方式通常不会让人联想到养鸡。
This was during the period when I considered myself to be a performance artist of a sort, a naked performance artist, to be specific.
那是在我自认为是某种行为艺术家——具体来说是裸体行为艺术家——的时期。
These days, Jonathan Gold is a food writer in Los Angeles. This all happened 15 years ago. He was putting together a performance. He had a PA system which could put out the requisite amount of annoying feedback sound at high decibels. He had the two full bottles of Glade American Beauty air freshener, which he would spray, in their entirety, in the performance space.
如今，乔纳森·戈尔德是洛杉矶的一名美食作家。这一切发生在15年前。他当时正在策划一场演出。他有一套音响设备，能发出足够高分贝的、令人讨厌的反馈声。他有两整瓶“Glade”牌美国之美空气清新剂，他会在表演空间里把它们全部喷掉。
And he had a live chicken, which he bought the day before the performance in one of those Chinese poultry markets in Los Angeles. And it comes the day of the show. An audience gathers in a darkened warehouse in West LA.
他还带了一只活鸡，是他在表演前一天从洛杉矶的一家华人禽类市场买的。演出当天，观众聚集在西洛杉矶一个漆黑的仓库里。
I don't know if you've been to a lot of performance art, but this was really typical of the stuff that was going on in the period. And I showed up, and I was naked. And I was carrying a machete, and I was blindfolded. And I stood in the middle of this pile of supermarket chickens, the broilers that you buy. And the chicken that I bought was tethered to a three-foot rope around me. And I hacked up and down blindly with a machete.
我不知道你们参加过多少行为艺术表演，但这在当时非常典型。我上场时是裸体的。我拿着一把砍刀，蒙着眼睛。我站在一堆超市买的肉鸡中间。我买的那只鸡用一根三英尺长的绳子拴在我周围。我盲目地挥舞着砍刀，上上下下地乱砍。
Toward the chicken, or just in general?
是对着鸡砍，还是随便乱砍？
Well, I was blindfolded, so I didn't know if it was towards the chicken or not. And I had fully intended that, in fact, I would kill the chicken in the midst of this performance. But chickens aren't that stupid. And this chicken wanted no part of the machete, stayed at the end of its rope the entire time, apparently.
嗯，我蒙着眼，所以不知道是不是对着鸡。我本来确实打算在表演中杀掉这只鸡。但鸡没那么蠢。显然，这只鸡一点都不想沾上那把砍刀，全程都待在绳子的尽头。
And after 10 minutes, when I was completely exhausted, I fell to a heap, and everybody left. And the performance was over. I don't know if you've stuck around after an art performance, but the few minutes after an art performance are some of the most depressing in the world.
10分钟后，我筋疲力尽，瘫倒在地，大家都走了。表演结束了。我不知道你们在艺术表演结束后有没有留下过，艺术表演结束后的几分钟是世界上最令人沮丧的时刻之一。
How so?
怎么说？
You've done your wad. You've done your bit for art, which has either worked or it hasn't. But you're sitting there. You're covered with chicken effluvia, in my case. It stinks to high hell. Everybody's gone, and you've got to clean up. And you're naked. It's really not a pretty picture.
你已经倾尽全力了。你为艺术尽了一份力，不管成功与否。但你坐在那里，身上沾满了鸡的排泄物——就我而言。臭得要命。所有人都走了，你还得收拾残局。而且你还光着身子。这画面实在不太美。
So Jonathan cleaned up. And when he was done, he had a chicken. And he didn't feel like he could kill the chicken. Destiny had brought them together. He felt like he could not turn his back.
所以乔纳森打扫干净了。打扫完后，他留下了这只鸡。他觉得没法杀掉它。命运让他们走到了一起。他觉得不能背弃它。
He says it was the same as if a kitten shows up on your back door, scratching, and lonely, and needy. So he took the chicken home. And in doing that, he stumbled across that thin, thin line that separates food items on the one hand from pets on the other, that divides the animals we eat from the animals we love.
他说这就像你家后门出现了一只又抓又叫、孤独无助的小猫一样。于是他把鸡带回了家。这样做的时候，他无意中跨过了那条细细的、将食物与宠物分隔开的界限，将我们吃的动物与我们爱的动物分开了。
So I get home, and I have this chicken. And I don't know what to do with it. So I spread out some newspaper on the top of my refrigerator, and I put the chicken up there.
我回到家，带着这只鸡。我不知道该拿它怎么办。于是我在冰箱顶上铺了一些报纸，把鸡放在上面。
I get a can of Green Giant brand niblets from under the counter. And I open it, and I put it in a little bowl for the chicken. And I give the chicken a little water. And the chicken's on top of my refrigerator.
我从柜台下拿了一罐“绿巨人”牌玉米粒。我打开它，倒进一个小碗里给鸡吃。然后给它准备了一点水。那只鸡就待在我的冰箱顶上。
Because you think chickens eat corn. You had read that or something. And that was the available corn.
因为你觉得鸡吃玉米。你可能读到过或者别的什么。那是手头现成的玉米。
That was the available corn. I wish I had thought better of the niblets idea.
那是手头仅有的玉米。我真希望当初能对“玉米粒”这个主意多想一点。
Why?
为什么？
Because in fact, if you're buying three or four cans of niblets a day, which is what the chicken ate, and you're existing on almost nothing, which I was, then your niblet bill turns out to be some two-figure percentage of your total income each week. If you can imagine living on $50 a week, but $10 of it goes for niblets. It's just hard to justify an expense like that.
因为实际上，如果你每天买三四罐玉米粒，而鸡就吃这个，你自己也几乎没什么东西吃——我当时的情况就是这样——那么你的玉米粒开销就占了你每周总收入的两位数百分比。如果你能想象每周只靠50美元生活，其中10美元还要花在玉米粒上。这种开销实在很难证明合理。
Though at the remove of 15 years, I think I can probably safely admit to you now that one of the reasons that I stuck with the niblets is because I liked saying the word "niblets" so much. And this gave me the excuse to use the words like "niblet" in general conversation several times a day. Usually, it just doesn't come up.
不过在15年后的今天，我想我可以坦白承认，我坚持喂它玉米粒的原因之一是因为我太喜欢说“玉米粒”（niblets）这个词了。这给了我在日常谈话中每天几次使用“玉米粒”这类词的机会。通常情况下，这种词根本用不上。
And the chicken stayed there, on top of my refrigerator, for a long time, months, six months, I think.
那只鸡就在那里，在我的冰箱顶上待了很长时间，好几个月，我想有六个月。
This is a one room apartment?
这是一个单间公寓吗？
A two room apartment. I had a kitchen and a bedroom. So I didn't have to look at the chicken when I was sleeping, though I did have to look at it when I was cooking.
一个两室的公寓。我有一个厨房和一个卧室。所以我睡觉时不用看着那只鸡，尽管做饭时必须看着它。
Did you ever cook chicken?
你吃过鸡肉吗？
Of course I cooked chicken.
我当然吃鸡肉。
Didn't you feel intensely disloyal?
你不觉得这极其不忠诚吗？
No, I felt no particular loyalty to this chicken. I don't know if you've ever had chickens, but it's not like-- you don't pet chickens. Chickens don't really like you to pet them. And you don't hold them. There's really no love that you feel for a chicken in your life, I don't think.
不，我对这只鸡没有特殊的忠诚感。我不知道你有没有养过鸡，但它不像……你不会去抚摸鸡。鸡真的不喜欢你摸它们。你也不会抱着它们。我不认为你这辈子会对一只鸡产生什么感情。
But yet you kept the chicken.
但你还是留下了这只鸡。
I kept the chicken because I couldn't bear to do anything else. And it's not like I could have carried it out onto Pico Boulevard and said, "Be free, little chicken. Be free."
我留下它是以为我无法忍受做其他事。而且我也不能把它带到皮科大道（Pico Boulevard）上说：“自由吧，小鸡，自由吧。”
Did you give the chicken a name?
你给鸡起名字了吗？
I never named the chicken. When I referred to the chicken in public, I always called it "the hen."
我从来没有给这只鸡起名。在公共场合提到它时，我总是叫它“那只母鸡”。
How did you not name it? It was a creature in your house.
你怎么会没给它起名？它是你家里的一个生物。
The chicken always seemed temporary. It never occurred to me that I might have the chicken as long as six months. The chicken always seemed like something that I would have for just a couple days.
这只鸡看起来总是暂时的。我从未想过会养它长达六个月。这只鸡看起来总是像是我只会养几天的那种东西。
And then what did you think was going to happen?
那当时你觉得会发生什么？
A, I thought about the chicken expiring. B, I have to admit that there was a possibility that someday, I would actually cook the chicken. I went through a lot of chicken recipes, hundreds and hundreds of chicken recipes.
A，我考虑过这只鸡会自然死亡。B，我得承认，有那么一天，我真的会把它煮了的可能性是存在的。我翻遍了大量的鸡肉食谱，成百上千种鸡肉食谱。
Thinking, "Maybe this'll be the recipe for my niblet-fed chicken?"
心想：“也许这就是我那只吃玉米粒长大的鸡的食谱？”
Exactly.
没错。
Possibly, I have to say, the most delicious chicken that you could ever eat, because of those niblets.
不得不说，因为吃了那些玉米粒，它可能是有史以来最好吃的鸡。
You can't buy niblet-fed chicken for love or money, I don't think. I'm not sure that a recipe existed that would have lived up to the fact of the chicken, this animal who you have come to know on fairly intimate terms, and who you have raised, and you have put a certain amount of emotion into.
我觉得无论花多少钱都买不到吃玉米粒长大的鸡。我不确定是否存在一种食谱能配得上这只鸡，这只你已经相当了解、朝夕相处，并且投入了一定感情的动物。
A chicken, if I might say, who has seen you naked.
如果我可以说的话，这只鸡还见过你光着身子。
The chicken did see me naked, damn it.
该死的，这只鸡确实见过我光着身子。
The fact is, we need food to be just food. And as soon as it becomes a living thing, especially if we're city people-- we're not used to the conversion of living things into our food-- it's hard to handle without thinking it has to be bigger than food, without wanting to make it ritualized or something bigger than food.
事实是，我们需要食物仅仅是食物。一旦它变成了一个活物，特别是如果我们是城里人——我们不习惯将活物转化为食物——就很难在不把它想得比食物更重要、不希望将其仪式化或赋予它某种意义的情况下处理它。
Exactly. Can I tell you a small story?
没错。我能给你讲个小故事吗？
Yeah, of course.
当然可以。
A few weeks ago, I was in this Korean restaurant in Koreatown in Los Angeles. It was this place called the Living Fish Center that I'd always wanted to go, because the name of it was so splendid. Living Fish Center, I imagine some sort of vast vivarium where Flipper was jumping through hoops and stuff.
几周前，我在洛杉矶韩国城的一家韩国餐厅。那地方叫“活鱼中心”（Living Fish Center），我一直想去，因为名字太炫了。活鱼中心，我以为是一个巨大的生态馆，海豚在那儿跳圈之类的。
And I go in there, and of course, it's just a crummy Korean restaurant. It's not that clean. And there are tanks and stuff, but I didn't know what to order.
我进去一看，当然，那只是个破破烂烂的韩国餐馆。不是很干净。里面有水箱什么的，但我不知道点什么。
So I order a fish soup because it looks like they have a small fish soup specialty on the menu. And it comes, and it's just really strong-smelling and not that great. And I try squid fried with bean sauce and onions, which wasn't that happening.
于是我点了一份鱼汤，因为菜单上看起来有小鱼汤特供。端上来后，味道太冲，不是很好吃。我又试了鱿鱼炒豆豉洋葱，也不怎么样。
And I'm about to give up and pay the check and go home with a vast table filled with uneaten stuff. And it suddenly occurs to me what the specialty of the restaurant is. And I wave the waitress over, and I tell her that I'd like a prawn.
我正打算放弃买单回家，桌上还剩下大堆没吃的东西。突然想到这家店的特色可能是什么。我招呼服务员过来，告诉她我要一只大虾。
And she is puzzled. She didn't expect me to ask for a prawn. But I repeat my request. And she shrugs and goes and tells the sushi chef.
她很困惑。她没想到我会要大虾。但我重复了要求。她耸耸肩，去告诉了寿司师傅。
And he goes to one side of the restaurant. And he climbs on this chair, this ordinary folding chair. And he reaches into this long tank that's running just below the ceiling. And he wiggles his fingers in the water. When he wiggles the fingers, the prawns just become enraged.
寿司师傅走到餐厅一侧。他爬上一把普通的折叠椅。伸手进了吊在天花板下的一长排大水缸里。他在水里动了动手指。当他动手指时，那些大虾立刻被激怒了。
And they start nipping at his fingers, and they start attacking him. And he picks out a couple of the liveliest ones and brings them back to his counter and, without washing his hands, mind you, just makes a few motions over it. And a couple seconds later, the waitress comes over with the prawns on this huge mound of ice.
它们开始夹他的手指，开始攻击他。他挑了几只最有活力的，带回柜台，甚至都没洗手，只是在那儿比划了几下。几秒钟后，服务员端着放在一大堆冰块上的大虾过来了。
Now what he'd done is he'd taken off the exoskeleton. The head was intact, and that little part of the tail that is always on prawns was still there. But the middle part is naked, like a grub.
他已经剥去了外骨骼。虾头是完整的，虾尾上那截总是保留的部分还在。但中间部分是赤裸的，就像一条蛆。
And I picked up the prawn with my chopsticks. And it was not dead, this prawn. It was extremely alive. And it was wiggling its legs. And it was wiggling its antennas.
我用筷子夹起大虾。它还没死，这只大虾。它极其活跃。它在扭动腿。它在摇动触须。
And its eyes were swiveling madly on its eye stalks. And it was looking back at me, seeing me as actually the predator, the creature that was going to eat it. And that was a really freakish moment, because as much stuff as I eat, and as low as I eat on the food chain, and as many prawns as I have dispatched in my life, I have never before killed a living being with my teeth.
它的眼睛在眼柄上疯狂地转动。它看着我，把我真正当成了掠食者，那个要吃掉它的生物。那是一个非常诡异的时刻，因为无论我吃多少东西，无论我在食物链底端吃多少，无论我一生中处理过多少大虾，我以前从未用牙齿杀死过一个活物。
And the prawn knew what I was going to do. And he did not like it. And I wasn't quite sure what to do, but if I put it down, the prawn would have died anyway. It's not going to live without its shell. Somebody else would've eaten it, blah, blah, blah.
大虾知道我要做什么。它不喜欢。我不太确定该怎么办，但如果我把它放下，它反正也会死。没有壳它活不了。别人也会吃掉它，诸如此类。
So I bit into it. I bit its body off with my teeth. And the prawn just relaxed in this way that was really eerie.
所以我咬了下去。我用牙齿咬断了它的身体。那只大虾就那样放松了下来，那种感觉非常阴森。
And the taste of the prawn, the taste of the meat of it, was extraordinary. It was sweet. It was like there was life coursing through it. It was the most alive thing I've ever eaten, obviously, literally. But again, it was freaky. It was getting too close to the actual nature of consumption, which is killing a living creature with your teeth.
大虾的味道，虾肉的味道，太特别了。它是甜的。就像生命在其中奔涌。显然，从字面上看，这是我吃过的最有生命力的东西。但再说一遍，这很怪异。它太接近进食的本质了，那就是用牙齿杀死一个活着的生物。
When you bit into the prawn, did you actually bite off its head, its living head, and have its head and its eyes in your mouth?
当你咬大虾时，你真的咬断了它的头，它活着的头，并且把它的头和眼睛放在了嘴里？
No. I bit off its body, and I held the head in my hands.
没有。我咬断了身体，把头拿在手里。
So you held the head in one hand and the tail in the other, and you bit the center.
所以你一只手拿着头，一只手拿着尾巴，咬的是中间。
Right. And I thought that I'd killed it. But in fact, when I put it down, it still had so much life in it that it grabbed a piece of salmon sashimi and wouldn't let go of it. And I don't think I ever want to do that again.
对。我以为我已经杀死了它。但事实上，当我把它放下时，它依然活力十足，以至于抓住了一片三文鱼刺身不肯松开。我想我再也不想那样做了。
Did you feel like there was something about the experience that made it more-- this word is a little cornier than I intend, but it's the only word that I can think of-- sacred, that took it out of the mundaneness of the way that we eat, which for most of us is eating without actually tasting and experiencing and thinking about what we're eating and what on the earth it is that we're killing to survive? Do you think in some way that it's more acceptable to eat an animal if you are more awake to the fact that it is an animal and what's happened to it? Or do you think it really doesn't matter?
你觉得这次经历是否让你觉得更……这个词比我打算用的要陈腐一点，但这是我唯一能想到的词——神圣？它让你脱离了我们进食的平庸方式，对我们大多数人来说，进食是不去品尝、不去体验、不去思考我们在吃什么、在这个地球上为了生存我们正在杀死什么的进食？你认为如果一个人更清醒地意识到它是一种动物以及它身上发生了什么，吃掉这只动物是否更让人能接受？还是说这真的不重要？
I think it matters a great deal. One of the greatest metaphors in Western civilization is that of Christ, who gave his life so that others might live. And I don't want to be sacrilegious, and I don't want to belittle that myth in any way.
我认为这非常重要。西方文明中最伟大的隐喻之一是基督，他献出了自己的生命以使他人得以生存。我不想亵渎神明，也不想贬低那个神话。
But a pig is giving its life so that we might eat. A chicken is giving its life so that we might eat. And I think the least that we could do is to think about that chicken, to think about that calf that we're eating. Not necessarily to be sad for it, but to celebrate it, to be aware of the being that it was, that it wasn't just this bit of bioengineered protein that somehow managed to find its way onto our plates.
但一头猪献出了它的生命以便我们食用。一只鸡献出了它的生命以便我们食用。我认为我们至少可以做到的，就是去思考那只鸡，去思考我们正在吃的那只小牛。不是一定要为它感到难过，而是要赞美它，要意识到它曾经是一个生命，而不仅仅是某种设法出现在我们盘子里的生物工程蛋白质。
Jonathan Gold writes his food column, "Counter Intelligence," for the LA Weekly. He's also the restaurant critic for Los Angeles magazine.
乔纳森·戈尔德为《洛杉矶周报》撰写美食专栏《柜台情报》（Counter Intelligence）。他也是《洛杉矶》杂志的餐厅评论家。
Act Two, Last Meal. Consider, please, poultry consumers, the role of poultry in Francois Mitterrand's last meal. Mitterrand, you'll recall, was the president of France, died at the beginning of 1996. A contradictory and enigmatic man, the French press used to call him the Sphinx. He once actually staged his own assassination to help himself in the polls. Obsessed with history and his place in it.
第二幕，《最后的晚餐》。请各位禽类消费者思考一下，禽类在弗朗索瓦·密特朗最后一餐中的作用。大家可能还记得，密特朗是法国总统，于1996年初去世。他是一个矛盾而神秘的人，法国媒体曾称他为“斯芬克斯”。他甚至曾为了在民调中获利而自导自演了一场刺杀。他痴迷于历史，以及他在历史中的地位。
Michael Paterniti wrote about Mitterrand's last meal for the magazine Esquire. Mitterrand found out that he was dying of cancer. Our story begins just weeks before his death.
迈克尔·帕特尼蒂为《时尚先生》杂志写了关于密特朗最后一餐的文章。密特朗发现自己身患癌症。我们的故事开始于他去世前几周。
Right before Christmas, Mitterrand went to Egypt to commune with the pharaohs. Even though he was extremely ill, he decided that he had to go there one last time.
圣诞节前夕，密特朗去了埃及，为了与法老们交流。尽管他病重，但他决定必须最后再去一次。
You said he went to Egypt commune with the pharaohs?
你说他去埃及是为了与法老交流？
Yeah.
是的。
Literally with the pharaohs?
字面意义上的与法老？
Well, he felt this spiritual connection to these leaders of the past. And he studied the lives, and in particular, how many of these people died, what their last gestures were. And he felt that his last gesture would have to be equally fitting.
嗯，他感到与这些过去的领袖有精神上的联系。他研究了他们的生活，特别是这些人是如何死亡的，他们最后的举动是什么。他觉得他最后的举动也必须是同样恰当的。
Equally grand.
同样宏大。
Yeah. And while he was there, he decided that he was going to have this amazing last meal. What he did was call back to France and made sure that they had this menu that he decided would be it, which was this amazing feast of oyster, and foie gras, and capon, and finally, this little songbird called ortolan, which symbolizes the French soul. And it was this completely forbidden thing to eat ortolan. It's illegal in France to do so.
是的。当他在那里时，他决定要吃这顿令人惊叹的最后晚餐。他做的是打回法国，确保他们按照他决定的菜单准备，这是一场由牡蛎、鹅肝、阉鸡组成的惊人盛宴，最后是这种被称为“圃鹀”（ortolan）的小鸣禽，它象征着法兰西灵魂。吃圃鹀是完全被禁止的。在法国这样做是违法的。
Because it's an endangered species, right?
因为这是濒危物种，对吧？
Yeah, and people who have served ortolan, chefs who've served it in France, have been fined. And I think in one case, a chef was imprisoned for serving it.
是的，在法国供应圃鹀的厨师曾被罚款。我想有一个案例中，一位厨师因为供应它而入狱。
Did you look at all into why the ortolan would come to represent the soul of France?
你有没有研究过为什么圃鹀会成为法国灵魂的代表？
It was the food of kings in France. And once it was caught in these tiny traps, in very old times, they would actually poke the eyes of the bird out. So the bird would live in complete darkness and just eat 24 hours a day. And then when it was fattened, they would drown it in a kind of cognac. And there was this ritual associated with the preparation of the bird, as well as with eating the bird.
它是法国君王的食物。在古代，一旦被这种小陷阱捕获，人们实际上会戳瞎鸟的眼睛。这样鸟就会生活在完全的黑暗中，一天24小时只顾吃。当它变肥后，他们会把它淹死在某种干邑白兰地中。这种鸟的准备工作以及吃法都有一套仪式。
Actually, in Proust and Fielding, ortolan appear. And they symbolize seduction, and adultery, and virginity.
事实上，在普鲁斯特（Proust）和菲尔丁（Fielding）的作品中都出现过圃鹀。它们象征着诱惑、通奸和纯洁。
And one of the things about ortolan is that people eat it with a napkin over their head.
关于圃鹀的一点是，人们在吃的时候会用餐巾蒙着头。
Right, people put a large cloth napkin over their head. And apparently, what the napkin does is it keeps the aroma inside this tent in which you're eating. And the French say that it also keeps God from seeing you eating the little birdie.
是的，人们会把一条大布餐巾蒙在头上。显然，餐巾的作用是把吃的时候散发的香气留在里面。法国人说这也能防止上帝看到你在吃这只小鸟。
Meaning what?
意思是？
Meaning that it's sinful, that the bird is so innocent.
意思是这是一种罪过，这只鸟太天真了。
And the pleasure so great?
而且带来的愉悦感太大了？
And the pleasure so great that it's a sin.
愉悦感太大了，以至于这是一种罪过。
And Mitterrand, when he had his last meal, he knew he was dying.
密特朗在吃最后一餐时，他知道自己快死了。
Right.
是的。
And he continued to survive for quite a while after the last meal, right?
而且他在那一餐后还坚持活了一段时间，对吧？
He lived eight days. And he didn't eat or drink during those days.
他活了八天。那几天里他没吃没喝。
He just decided he wanted the last food that he had eaten to be the ortolan.
他只是决定，他希望最后吃下的食物是圃鹀。
Yeah. That was what was most incredible to me is that he had this huge dinner, and then consciously decided that would be his last meal, and then just readied himself for death.
是的。这对我来说最不可思议的是，他吃了一顿大餐，然后有意识地决定那将是他的最后一餐，然后就做好了死亡的准备。
So you arranged to go to France to try to taste this bird and have this meal, in fact, to try to recreate Mitterrand's last meal.
所以你安排去法国尝试品尝这种鸟，去吃这顿饭，事实上，是为了尝试重现密特朗的最后一餐。
Right. And it started with 100 phone calls just to try to locate somebody who would even entertain the notion. And after, literally, months, there was one chef in Bordeaux who said that he would cook the meal.
没错。我打了100个电话，才试着找到一个愿意考虑这个念头的人。在几个月之后，波尔多有一位厨师说他愿意做这顿饭。
And so you have this massive meal, ending with the bird.
于是你们吃了那顿盛大的晚餐，最后吃了那只鸟。
Yes.
是的。
And what do we know about when Mitterrand ate the bird?
关于密特朗吃那只鸟的时候，我们知道什么？
Well, we know that during the meal, he slipped in and out of consciousness in between the courses. And he would eat ravenously, and then he would just sort of pass out. And he sat at a table separate from the table where all his guests were seated. There were about 30 people there, extended family and friends.
嗯，我们知道在用餐期间，他在每道菜之间陷入了昏迷。他会狼吞虎咽地吃，然后就晕过去了。他坐在一个和所有客人的桌子分开的餐桌旁。大约有30个人在那里，包括大家庭成员和朋友。
And Mitterrand would rise up with each new course and eat. But he really wasn't talking to many people. And he was really focused on trying to finish the meal and taste, apparently, every note in that meal.
密特朗每上一道新菜都会起身进食。但他并没有和太多人交谈。他全神贯注地想吃完这顿饭，品尝那顿饭中的每一个音符。
When you had your meal, do you feel like you were able to achieve that level of awareness, where  you were tasting every note of the meal? It seems like such a high standard to aspire to.
当你吃那顿饭时，你觉得你达到了那种觉悟水平吗？你能品尝到饭菜的每一个音符吗？这似乎是一个很高的追求标准。
I felt like it was the most incredible meal I've eaten. And it was because I was very focused on everything that went into my mouth, and also, because when it came to the ortolan, there's no easy way to eat ortolan. You are forced to taste every bite. And it goes from being completely sublime to being excruciating.
我觉得那是我吃过的最不可思议的一顿饭。因为我非常专注地对待送进嘴里的每一件事物，而且，当涉及到圃鹀时，没有简单的吃法。你被迫品尝每一口。那种感觉从完全的升华变成了痛苦。
Describe what it's like to eat the bird. We should say that the bird, you describe it as the size of your thumb, smaller than your thumbs.
描述一下吃这种鸟的感觉。我们应该说这只鸟，你描述它像你的拇指大小，比拇指还小。
Yeah, it is. It's about the size of your thumb. And they serve it in a white cassoulet. And you put the napkin over your head, and you duck down toward the cassoulet. And so you are in this space that is completely white, the white napkin, the white plate, the white cassoulet. And then you have the bird on its back that you lift up and put into your mouth. You cool it by breathing in and out.
是的，就是那样。大约只有拇指那么大。它们放在一个白色的砂锅里。你把餐巾蒙在头上，弯下腰靠近砂锅。所以你身处在这个完全白色的空间里——白餐巾、白盘子、白砂锅。然后你拿起仰面朝天的鸟放进嘴里。通过吸气和呼气来给它降温。
And this is the entire bird, every part of it.
这是一整只鸟，每一个部分？
Yes. In our case, the chef insisted that we bite off the head and leave the head on the plate. I think in Mitterrand's case, he ate the head, too.
是的。在我们的例子中，厨师坚持我们要咬掉头，把头留在盘子里。我想密特朗的情况是，他也把头吃了。
OK. So you bite off the head. You leave the head on the plate.
好吧。所以你咬掉了头。你把头留在盘子里。
And then you cool it, and then you begin to chew. And that first bite is incredibly difficult to describe, because it's terrifying. I was terrified. I was nauseous with the idea of it.
然后你给它降温，然后开始咀嚼。第一口的味道很难描述，因为太可怕了。我当时吓坏了。我被这个主意搞得反胃。
But the first bite of the bird changed that. It was incredibly and almost immediately delicious. And all these juices were flowing out of it into your mouth and mingling and commingling with everything that was already in your mouth. And it's like this very finely evolved consomme.
但那只鸟的第一口彻底改变了这一点。它极其且几乎立即变得美味。所有的汁液都从中流进你的嘴里，与嘴里原有的东西混合在一起。就像一碗经过极其精细熬制的清汤。
And then you begin to taste the meat. And they're little, tender bits of meat. And then, I think you begin to taste the organs. And it becomes more bitter. So the sweetness and the tenderness turns bitter.
然后你开始尝到肉味。那是些小块的、嫩滑的肉。然后我想你开始尝到内脏的味道。它变得更苦了。所以甜蜜和嫩滑转变成了苦涩。
And then?
然后呢？
And then, well, you keep chewing ortolan until you have chewed it completely. And then you're supposed to swallow it all at once. And there's no other way, really, to consume it. And as you continue to chew, it gets harder and harder, because you're working the bones, finally.
然后，嗯，你一直咀嚼圃鹀直到嚼碎。然后你应该一次把它全咽下去。真的没有别的方法来消耗它。当你继续咀嚼时，它变得越来越难，因为你终于嚼到了骨头。
So the meat and the juices fade. And you suddenly are chewing these bones. And that is when you really, I think, fall into a bit of an existential crisis. Like, what the hell am I doing? And then also, I really think I'm going to throw up.
所以肉和汁液消失了。你突然开始咀嚼这些骨头。那就是我认为你真正陷入某种存在危机的时候。就像，我到底在做什么？然后我还真的以为我要吐了。
And how am I going to swallow these bones?
你怎么把这些骨头咽下去？
And how am I going to swallow them? Many people who have never had ortolan before end up spitting it out on the plate. And in fact, at Mitterrand's last meal, a number of the people in the room did spit out their ortolan.
你怎么咽下去？很多以前没吃过圃鹀的人最终会把它吐在盘子里。事实上，在密特朗的最后一餐中，房间里的一些人确实吐出了他们的圃鹀。
That seems like incredibly bad form, though. You're spitting out the soul of France.
但那看起来是极其没教养的做法。你在吐掉法兰西的灵魂。
Yeah, you're incredibly gauche if you pull that stunt.
是的，如果你搞这种把戏，那是极其笨拙的。
Did this experience change you?
这次经历改变了你吗？
Yeah, it definitely changed me. I didn't eat chicken for a long time.
是的，它彻底改变了我。我很久都没吃鸡肉。
Why?
为什么？
Because I think I felt guilty.
因为我想我感到内疚。
Guilty like you didn't feel like it was right to eat a bird without the sacred quality that it had to eat the ortolan?
内疚得像你觉得吃掉一只鸟如果没有吃圃鹀那样的神圣品质就不对劲一样？
Yeah, I think it has everything to do with feeling, in some ways, like I had actually eaten the last meal. And for me to put anything else inside of my body would mean that it would have to be somehow as sacred, or holy, or as good. And it's not like I am suddenly a vegetarian now. Finally, I ate whatever, because I was hungry, without thinking about, for instance, the life that I was putting inside of me.
是的，我想这和感觉在某种程度上我确实吃掉了“最后一餐”有关。对我来说，再往身体里放任何东西，意味着它必须在某种程度上同样神圣、神圣或美好。我并不是突然成了素食主义者。最终，我还是随便吃了些什么，因为我饿了，而没有考虑到，例如，我正在放入我体内的那个生命。
Was it a relief not to taste the food again?
不再品尝食物是一种解脱吗？
Yeah, because it takes a lot of energy and concentration. And it takes faith, and all of these things that we don't associate with eating, when you really taste a meal. It takes concentration and silence. And at the same time, understand how that meal came to your table.
是的，因为那需要大量的精力和专注。它需要信念，以及所有我们不与进食联系在一起的东西，当你真的去品尝一顿饭时。它需要专注和沉默。同时，还要理解那顿饭是怎么来到你餐桌上的。
The way you describe it, it's almost like you're saying that if we were really awake to what the world is giving us in a given meal, it would be hard eat the meal every single time.
你描述它的方式，几乎像是说如果我们真的清醒地意识到这个世界在某顿饭中给了我们什么，那么每次吃饭都会变得很困难。
Yeah, I feel like we would age really quickly.
是的，我觉得我们会老得很快。
Do you think we would age because we'd be doing so much thinking and so much mental work during the meal?
你认为我们会变老是因为我们在用餐时进行了太多的思考和心理工作？
Yeah, it'd be like a time-lapse version of your life, if you were psychically, spiritually, physically, intellectually, erotically present at every meal.
是的，如果你在每一顿饭时都能在心理、精神、身体、智力、感官上做到全神贯注，那将会是你生命的一个延时版本。
But you're saying that we have to deaden ourselves in order to live.
但你是说为了活着，我们必须让自己麻木。
I think we do, to a degree.
我想在某种程度上我们是这样。
But I think-- I have to say, what's radical about what you're saying is you're saying, maybe that isn't such a horrible thing. Maybe that actually has to be the way.
但我认为——我必须说，你的话里最激进的部分是，你在说，也许那并不是什么可怕的事。也许那确实必须是这样的方式。
I wish it weren't. But I don't think we make enough time to eat. And if we haven't made enough time to eat, then it's better not to taste what we are eating. It's easier.
我希望不是这样。但我觉得我们没有足够的时间去进食。如果我们没有留出足够的时间去进食，那么不去品尝我们正在吃的东西会更好。那样更容易。
Michael Paterniti in Portland, Maine. Coming up, a woman who thinks that This American Life is bad for an entire species, and when a perfumed handkerchief does not do what you want it to do. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
迈克尔·帕特尼蒂在缅因州波特兰市。接下来，一位女士认为《美国生活》对整个物种有害，还有当香水手帕没有达到你想要的效果时。我们的节目将在国际公共广播电台的一分钟后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of stories on that theme. Today, during the weeks between Thanksgiving and Christmas, the time of year when poultry consumption is at its greatest in this country, we bring you our annual Poultry Slam, stories of chickens, turkeys, ducks, fowl of all kind, and our relationship with them. We have come to act three of our program, Act Three, People who Love Birds and Hate This American Life.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天，在感恩节和圣诞节之间——这个国家禽类消费量最大的时期——我们为您带来我们一年一度的“禽类大乱斗”，讲述鸡、火鸡、鸭子、各类家禽的故事，以及我们与它们的关系。我们来到了节目的第三幕，第三幕，《爱鸟之人与讨厌〈美国生活〉的人》。
Well, I hold in my hand a stack of, I'd say that it's about 50 letters that I've received from around the country. Here is one from Yonkers, New York. It begins, "Dear Mr. Glass, I was profoundly shocked to learn that for two years in a row, during the Thanksgiving and Christmas season, you have produced a Poultry Slam program, in which cruel and demeaning jokes and anecdotes are told about chickens and turkeys." Here's another letter from Santa Monica. It begins, "Dear Mr. Glass, we were profoundly shocked to learn that for two years in a row, during the Thanksgiving and Christmas season, you have produced a Poultry Slam program--"
好吧，我手里拿着一叠信，我想大约有50封，是我从全国各地收到的。这有一封来自纽约扬克斯的。开头是：“亲爱的格拉斯先生，得知在过去两年里的感恩节和圣诞节期间，您制作了‘禽类大乱斗’节目，在节目中讲述了关于鸡和火鸡的残忍和贬损的笑话和轶事，我感到深受震惊。”这里还有一封来自圣莫尼卡的信。开头是：“亲爱的格拉斯先生，得知在过去两年里的感恩节和圣诞节期间，您制作了‘禽类大乱斗’节目——”
The wording is identical in these. In fact, the wording is identical in most of the letters. The first wave of mail was organized by a woman named Karen Davis, head and founder of a group called United Poultry Concerns. We invited her onto the program to correct whatever misinformation she thought we were spreading. She, in turn, invited me out to her home, out in poultry country in eastern Virginia.
这些信的措辞是一模一样的。事实上，大多数信件的措辞都完全相同。第一批邮件是由一位名叫卡伦·戴维斯（Karen Davis）的女士组织的，她是“联合家禽关注组织”（United Poultry Concerns）的创始人和负责人。我们邀请她参加节目，纠正她认为我们传播的任何错误信息。作为回报，她邀请我去她位于弗吉尼亚州东部家禽之乡的家中。
OK, birds, let's go.
好了，鸟儿们，出发吧。
Every morning, Karen lets 55 birds out of the converted garage behind her house. They stay in there overnight as protection against predators.
每天早上，卡伦会把55只鸟从她屋后的改建车库里放出来。它们晚上待在那里是为了防范捕食者。
It's OK. Come on. Hi, birds. Come on out.
没关系。来吧。嘿，鸟儿们。出来吧。
It's a lovely, friendly chaos, like a scene from Dr. Doolittle.
这是一种可爱、友好的混乱，就像《怪医杜立德》（Dr. Doolittle）里的场景。
[ROOSTER CROWING]
[公鸡打鸣]
All right, good. Go on outside.
好了，很好。到外面去。
Nearly all of these birds are refugees from the commercial poultry industry. Karen started taking care of birds that had fallen out of trucks, or had been left behind, or escaped. She let animal shelters know that she would care for chickens. People started bringing her birds. She gets birds from school hatching projects. And now, she's got a big, fenced-in back yard full of them.
这些鸟几乎全是商业禽类行业的难民。卡伦开始照顾那些从卡车上掉下来，或者被遗弃，或者逃跑的鸟。她让动物收容所知道她会照顾鸡。人们开始把鸟送到她这里。她从学校的孵化项目中接收鸟。现在，她有一个巨大的、围起来的后院，里面全是它们。
These two roosters are the kinds of birds who are used by the meat industry. As you can see, they're extremely large, very overweight. They're crippled. They're typical.
这两只公鸡是肉食行业使用的那种鸟。正如你所看到的，它们非常大，非常超重。它们是残疾的。它们很典型。
When you say crippled, how are they crippled?
你说残疾，它们是怎么残疾的？
Well, one is sitting because he can't get up. And they have skeletal problems. It's their entire skeleton through their system is just not able to accommodate the rapidly growing body that's imposed upon the skeletal system when they're young. So they are very susceptible to being crippled and to having a wide range of skeletal diseases.
嗯，一只坐着，因为站不起来。它们有骨骼问题。它们的整个骨骼系统无法容纳在它们年幼时强加给骨骼系统的快速生长的身体。所以它们非常容易残疾，并患上各种骨骼疾病。
In nature, it takes a chicken six months to grow to full maturity. But with selective breeding and specially formulated feed, the poultry industry now raises a bird to full size in just six weeks. Then they're butchered.
在自然界中，一只鸡需要六个月才能发育完全成熟。但通过选择性育种和专门配制的饲料，禽类行业现在仅需六周就能将鸟养成完全成熟。然后它们就被宰杀了。
What Karen Davis is doing is keeping birds alive that are not designed to live very long. Putting on all this extra weight so fast, so young, strains the heart and lungs, she says. And typically, their bodies give out when they're just two years old. That's versus traditional breeds, which can live 10, 15 years.
卡伦·戴维斯所做的是让那些注定活不长的鸟活着。她说，这么年轻就长这么快，会增加心脏和肺部的压力。通常，它们在两岁时身体就会垮掉。而传统品种则可以活10到15年。
And what she finds when she cares for these birds in a loving way, outside the crowded chicken houses they were born into, is that they defy the stereotypes that most people have about chickens. They're not stupid, or dirty, or cold-hearted. Take Henry, one of the first birds Karen brought home.
当她以充满爱心的方式照顾这些鸟，让它们离开出生的拥挤鸡舍时，她发现它们推翻了大多数人对鸡的刻板印象。它们并不愚蠢、肮脏或冷酷无情。以亨利为例，他是卡伦带回家的第一批鸟之一。
Henry had fallen off a truck. He was from a breeder operation. He had a severely debeaked upper beak. And he was covered with filth. He eventually became very snowy white. And he was very scared of people. And he was like anybody who's lived as a creature with no identity in a mass situation. He had no sense of who he was or where he was.
亨利从卡车上掉了下来。他来自一个育种场。他上喙被严重切除。他全身沾满污垢。他最终变成了雪白的样子。他非常怕人。他就像任何一个在群体环境中没有身份的生物一样。他对自己是谁或自己在哪里一无所知。
But this changed. After he had been with me and my husband for about three or four months, he became very, very affectionate. He liked to be held. His feathers came in very beautifully. And he became a very sweet, affectionate bird. And he would come when I would call him up the back steps. And he--
但这改变了。在我和我丈夫身边待了大约三四个月后，他变得非常、非常有感情。他喜欢被抱。他的羽毛长得非常漂亮。他变成了一只非常甜美、有感情的鸟。当我叫他上后台阶时，他会过来。他——
Here's one area where Karen Davis is completely in the right, and I and my radio staff have been absolutely wrong. In our earlier Poultry Slams, three or four times, people referred to chickens as stupid, as having no personality. In last year's show, at one point, I myself declared that if chickens had a personality, that personality seemed to be that they're a pain in the ass. And while this may be true for the chickens I observed, which were raised in the crowded gulag of commercial production, chickens raised properly, well, they can be kind of sweet.
在这一方面，卡伦·戴维斯完全正确，而我和我的广播员工绝对是错了。在我们早期的“禽类大乱斗”中，人们三四次把鸡称为愚蠢的，称它们没有个性。在去年的节目中，有一次，我自己宣称如果鸡有个性，那个性似乎就是令人厌烦。虽然对于我观察到的那些生长在商业生产拥挤古拉格里的鸡来说这可能是真的，但饲养得当的鸡，嗯，它们可以很可爱。
Want to demonstrate your sweetness? Do you? This hen has been with us since she was 10 weeks old. Haven't you been?
想展示你的甜美吗？是吗？这只母鸡从10周大就一直和我们在一起。不是吗？
Karen showed me Ella, who likes her neck stroked. And Elise, who jumps over the fence every morning and jumps back in every night. And Lois and Lambrusco, a pair who stick together all the time. And Dolores, who's sort of shy. She says meat-eaters like me usually don't like to think that chickens have personalities, because then it would be too hard to eat them.
卡伦向我展示了埃拉（Ella），她喜欢被抚摸脖子。还有伊莉丝（Elise），她每天早上跳过栅栏，每天晚上跳回来。还有洛伊斯（Lois）和蓝布鲁斯科（Lambrusco），一对总是粘在一起的伙伴。还有多洛雷斯（Dolores），她有点害羞。她说像我这样的肉食者通常不喜欢去想鸡有个性，因为那样吃它们就太困难了。
They're very homey birds. That's another thing is if you brought a chair out here, and you were sitting out here reading a book, or working on something, or you sat out on the steps, they'll all collect around you. They like to be with you. They like to sit with you. They like to preen themselves next to you. And they'll sit with you for hours. That was one of the first things that drew me to them.
它们是非常顾家的鸟。还有一点，如果你带一把椅子到这里，坐在这里看书，或者做点什么，或者坐在台阶上，它们都会聚在你身边。它们喜欢和你在一起。它们喜欢和你坐在一起。它们喜欢在你身边梳理羽毛。它们会陪你坐上几个小时。这是最初吸引我的地方之一。
We hung around the yard for half an hour and then went inside. She made a pot of coffee. And when we got to discussing This American Life , I have to say the mood got a good bit chillier. Karen Davis sees our annual Poultry Slam as one long piece of insensitive, anti-chicken propaganda.
我们在院子里待了半个小时，然后进屋了。她煮了一壶咖啡。当我们开始讨论《美国生活》时，不得不说气氛变得冷淡多了。卡伦·戴维斯认为我们年度的“禽类大乱斗”是一长串麻木不仁的、反鸡的宣传。
I thought it was a disgusting show. And it was just in the typical tradition of let's make dirty jokes about poultry and do it in a variety of voices. And it's just a mean-spirited show. It's very irresponsible, very irresponsible, to present lies, to really just take a collage of hostile attitudes and complacent, smirking voices and put them all together and feel that we're doing something worthwhile. I understand that the show says something to the effect that this is about America, and this American life, and how we see ourselves. And it's really about us and not about them. But it's the birds who get the bad rap.
我觉得那是个恶心的节目。它只是延续了讲关于家禽的脏笑话并以各种声音表演的传统。这是一个居心不良的节目。呈现谎言，真正地把一堆敌对的态度和自满、讥笑的声音放在一起，并觉得我们在做有价值的事情，这是非常不负责任的，非常不负责任。我明白节目说这是关于美国，关于这种美国生活，以及我们如何看待自己。它实际上是关于我们，而不是关于它们。但鸟儿们却背了黑锅。
If you've heard much of today's program at all, if you didn't just turn on your radio a moment or two ago, then you got a pretty good sense of the tone of our previous Poultry Slams. And even stories that actually tried to document cruelty to poultry, for instance one woman's rather grim memoir of growing up on a turkey farm, even this, Karen found offensive in tone and in spirit.
如果你听过今天节目的很大一部分，如果你不是刚打开收音机，那你应该对我们之前“禽类大乱斗”的基调有了相当不错的了解。即使是那些试图记录对家禽残忍行为的故事，例如一位女士关于在火鸡农场成长的相当阴郁的回忆录，即使是这个，卡伦也觉得在基调和精神上是冒犯的。
I pointed out that half the stories in previous years had not even been about real chickens. One was about a duck hand puppet. One was about a radio superhero called Chicken Man. One was an opera about Chicken Little, staged entirely with finger puppets.
我指出，前几年一半的故事甚至不是关于真实的鸡。一个是关于手偶鸭子的。一个是关于被称为“鸡人”的广播超级英雄。一个是关于“小鸡快跑”的歌剧，完全是用手指木偶表演的。
[MUSIC PLAYING  FROM "LA PULCINA PICCOLA"]
[播放歌剧〈小鸡快跑〉音乐]
But Karen would have none of it.
但卡伦一点也不听。
I remember this woman speaking about the chicken as opera diva, which again, of course, was just a joke, and about Chicken Little being an opera diva. That itself is, again, disparaging. It's not the worst kind of thing you can do. But the woman's whole voice, the very tone of her voice, the attitude, the way she talked about chickens, was not in a spirit of goodwill. It's an ill-willed presentation.
我记得这个女人谈论鸡作为歌剧女主角，当然那又是一个笑话，谈论“小鸡快跑”是歌剧女主角。那本身又是一种贬低。这不是你能做的最糟糕的事。但那个女人整个声音，她说话的语气、态度，她谈论鸡的方式，并不是出于善意。这是一个心怀恶意的陈述。
I just have to differ with you. When I think about the woman in that story, she's very affectionate towards the characters in her opera.
我不得不和你持不同意见。当我想到那个故事里的女人时，她对她歌剧里的角色非常有感情。
She made some hostile comments about chickens, again, that had no connection to who chickens even are. And maybe she doesn't even know any chickens herself. She's just doing what so many people do. She's just talking off the top of her head. And chickens are easy to, again, make into characters who you can laugh and smirk over.
她对鸡发表了一些敌对评论，同样，这些评论与鸡究竟是什么毫无关联。也许她自己根本不认识任何鸡。她只是像许多人那样做。她只是信口开河。而鸡很容易被变成你可以嘲笑和讥讽的角色。
But I guess I'm saying, she's not laughing and smirking. She loves her chicken characters, like all the birds in the thing. She clearly loves them.
但我猜我在说，她并没有在嘲笑和讥讽。她爱她的鸡角色，就像节目里的所有鸟一样。她显然爱它们。
She said something to the effect on that show that chickens had no personalities and didn't know who they were. I don't remember exactly what it was. But it was one of those kinds of statements.
她在那个节目中说了类似鸡没有个性，不知道自己是谁之类的话。我不记得具体是什么了。但它是那种陈述之一。
But that was just one moment in a story that, in a certain way, had less to do with chickens and much more to do with what it means to create something emotional and grand out of something so small as finger puppets. Karen Davis and I argued for a long time about whether there was anything in our program at all, besides slander against chickens. And in the end, we simply do not agree. I asked her why, if there's this genocide of millions of chickens a day, with ads on television encouraging people to tear at chickens' flesh with their teeth, ads that reach many more people than we do on our radio show, why go after us?
但这只是一个故事中的一刻，从某种程度上说，那个故事与鸡的关系较小，而与如何用手指木偶这样微小的东西创造出情感和宏大的东西关系更大。卡伦·戴维斯和我争论了很久，关于我们的节目中除了对鸡的诽谤之外是否还有其他东西。最终，我们根本无法达成一致。我问她，如果每天有数百万只鸡被种族灭绝，电视上有广告鼓励人们用牙齿撕扯鸡肉，这些广告覆盖的人数比我们的广播节目多得多，为什么针对我们？
Do you feel like somehow by stopping us, that that's going to change the situation for chickens, that that's going to have an impact on the number of birds killed and mistreated?
你是否觉得以某种方式阻止我们就能改变鸡的处境，这会对被杀害和虐待的鸟类数量产生影响？
It could. You're part of the problem. As long as you do this show called a Poultry Slam, you're part of the problem. You're one of the reasons. You're one of the many components of the abuse. You're part of the problem.
可能会。你是问题的一部分。只要你做这个叫“禽类大乱斗”的节目，你就是问题的一部分。你是原因之一。你是虐待的众多组成部分之一。你是问题的一部分。
[MUSIC - "CHICKENS" BY HARRY BELAFONTE]
[播放哈里·贝拉方特的歌曲《鸡》]
Act Four, Meaning of a Chicken. For most of us who have little to no contact with living, breathing chickens, the fact is that chickens mean what we decide that they mean. We have this story from David Rakoff, which begins far, far away from any chicken house.
第四幕，《鸡的意义》。对于我们大多数与活着的、呼吸的鸡几乎没有接触的人来说，事实是鸡的意义在于我们决定它们意味着什么。我们有大卫·拉科夫的这个故事，它开始于远离任何鸡舍的地方。
Friday nights of my childhood and early adolescence were spent at weekly meetings of a socialist, Zionist, youth movement. My brother, sister, and I were members. The meetings took a variety of forms. There were the earnest discussions of Marx and the great labor Zionist thinkers like Theodore Herzl and A. D. Gordon, bull sessions about who in the group had hurt whose feelings, and playing air guitar to "Come Sail Away" by Styx. All activities that formed us into pretty deeply committed young socialists, ready at the age of 15 for the ultimate prize the movement could bestow, a summer living and working on a kibbutz, one of the collective farms that were a central part of settling the Jewish state.
我童年和青春期早期的周五晚上是在一个社会主义、犹太复国主义青年运动的每周会议上度过的。我的兄弟、姐妹和我都是成员。会议采取了多种形式。有对马克思和像西奥多·赫茨尔（Theodore Herzl）和A·D·戈登（A. D. Gordon）这样伟大的劳工犹太复国主义思想家的认真讨论，关于小组中谁伤害了谁的感情的争论，以及对着斯汀（Styx）乐队的《Come Sail Away》弹空气吉他。所有这些活动将我们塑造成相当坚定的年轻社会主义者，在15岁时就准备好去争取运动所能给予的最高奖赏——一个在基布兹（kibbutz）生活和工作的夏天，这是构成定居犹太国家核心部分的集体农场之一。
There, we would meet other members of the movement from all over the world and spend many a happy hour engaged in honest labor, laughingly baling sheaves of wheat, picking olives, oranges, peaches, grapes, the sweat on our brows a shining reminder of the nobility of collective farming. In the evenings, we would gather together and dance around the fire, sing Crosby, Stills, Nash, & Young songs and, if one's older siblings were any indication, lose our virginity. Years later, we would renounce our bourgeois upbringings and return to Israel, making lives of simple, agrarian bliss. This would all change for me in one single evening, in a shed of 5,000 chickens.
在那里，我们将见到来自世界各地的其他运动成员，并度过许多快乐时光从事诚实的劳动，欢笑着捆扎麦捆，采摘橄榄、橙子、桃子、葡萄，眉间的汗水是集体农耕崇高性的闪亮提醒。晚上，我们会聚在一起围着火堆跳舞，唱Crosby, Stills, Nash, & Young的歌，如果年长的兄弟姐妹有什么暗示的话，还会失去童贞。多年后，我们将抛弃我们的资产阶级背景回到以色列，过上简单的、农业性的幸福生活。这一切对于我来说，在一个拥有5000只鸡的棚子里，在一个晚上就彻底改变了。
The kibbutz I was assigned to was one of the oldest in Israel, settled in 1928 by Jews from Russia, Poland, and Germany. For the most part, our arrival was met with little to no notice. We were just another group of volunteers, no different from the countless other Europeans and Australians just passing through, taking time out to pick fruit, work on their tans, and contract cystitis from their rampant and unchecked coitus. But we were different. We were members of the movement.
我被分配到的基布兹是以色列最古老的基布兹之一，由来自俄罗斯、波兰和德国的犹太人在1928年定居。大多数情况下，我们的到来几乎没有引起注意。我们只是又一群志愿者，与无数路过的欧洲人和澳大利亚人没什么不同，抽时间来采摘水果、晒黑皮肤，并因猖獗和未受控制的性交而患上膀胱炎。但我们不同。我们是该运动的成员。
I thought that our political ardor would be immediately apparent. I had visions of our bus being greeted by garlanded, folk-dancing youth, so happy to have us there to share in their dream. I had been raised on a fairly steady diet of just such socialist, utopian Ziegfeld numbers, songs, film strips, and oral histories that all attested to just this scenario.
我以为我们的政治热情会立刻显现出来。我幻想着我们的巴士会被佩戴花环、跳民族舞的年轻人迎接，他们很高兴我们能在那里分享他们的梦想。我是在大量这种社会主义、乌托邦式的齐格菲尔德（Ziegfeld）式的数字、歌曲、电影胶片和口述历史中长大的，所有这些都证明了这种情景。
Trees weren't simply trees. They were jungle gyms of plenty, with smiling children clambering over their branches. A field was somewhere you brought your guitar, so that your comrades could dance down the rows after the day's work was over.
树木不仅仅是树木。它们是丰富的丛林健身房，孩子们在树枝上爬来爬去，笑容满面。田野是你带着吉他的地方，这样你的战友们可以在一天工作结束后沿着行间跳舞。
I was assigned to pick pears. Work would begin at 4:00 AM and finish sometime mid-morning, before the heat had set in. How filled with fervor I was that first morning, the light barely dawning as I headed out in the back of the truck, wearing my simple work shirt, a pair of shorts, and the traditional sun hat worn by so many pioneers who had come before me to make the desert bloom. I should pause here to point out that we actually said things like "make the desert bloom," all the time. So off I headed to the orchard.
我被分配去采摘梨。工作从凌晨4点开始，在早晨酷热到来之前结束。那个第一天的早晨我是多么充满热情，光线刚刚破晓，我坐着卡车的后斗出发，穿着简单的工作衬衫、短裤，戴着许多先辈用来让沙漠开花的那种传统的太阳帽。我应该在这里停顿一下，指出我们实际上一直说“让沙漠开花”之类的话。于是我就去了果园。
I know I sound like the Central Casting New Yorker I've turned myself into with single-minded determination when I say this, but the main problem with working in the fields is that the sun is just always shining. Dyed-in-the-wool Northerner that I am, it became apparent after about two days that I was completely unsuited to working outside. And I was moved around among the kibbutz's various interior jobs, the furniture factory, the metal irrigation parts factory, and the kitchen, assured all the while by the group leader that there was nothing emasculating or ersatz socialist in being moved inside. After all, each according to his needs, each according to his abilities. My abilities seemed to lie in passing out from heat stroke after a scant two hours in an orchard.
我知道我说这话时听起来像是我以坚定不移的决心将自己变成的那个来自纽约的选角典型，但田间工作的主要问题是阳光总是明媚的。作为一个彻头彻尾的北方人，大约两天后就很明显，我根本不适合在户外工作。我在基布兹的各种室内工作中被调来调去，家具厂、金属灌溉零件厂和厨房，小组长一直向我保证，被调到室内并没有什么阉割或伪社会主义色彩。毕竟，各尽所能，各取所需。我的能力似乎在于在果园里待了区区两个小时后就因中暑而昏倒。
This continued for weeks. It was a somewhat idyllic, if not a mite monotonous existence, that is, until the long night of the chickens. The boys of our group were gathered together one day and told in the hushed tones reserved for trying to avert impending disaster that we would forgo our regular work details and spend the night from midnight until dawn packing truckloads of poultry.
这种情况持续了数周。这是一种有些田园诗般，如果不是有点单调的生活，直到那个漫长的鸡之夜。有一天，我们小组的男生被召集在一起，用那种通常用来防止即将来临的灾难的低沉语气被告知，我们将放弃常规工作，从午夜到黎明整晚打包卡车装载的家禽。
Why this needed to be done with such urgent secrecy under cover of night and why the girls were excused was never explained to us. And we didn't ask. We greeted the news with the respectful Hemingway silence of the Y chromosome, no dopey girls allowed. It was all imbued with nocturnal, testicular melodrama, like some summer stock production of Das Boot.
为什么这需要在夜色掩护下如此紧急地秘密进行，以及为什么女生被免除，从未向我们解释。我们也没有问。我们用Y染色体特有的海明威式的沉默迎接了这个消息，没有笨蛋女孩允许参与。这一切都充满了夜间的、睾丸酮式的戏剧性，就像《从海底出击》（Das Boot）的某种夏季档演出。
We slept that evening from 9:00 to 11:00, what I would come to know later, in a far different context, as a disco nap. We rose, drank some tea. The girls sprayed perfume into some handkerchiefs for us to wear around our noses and mouths. And we were off in trucks to do battle with the insurgent chickens. The scene had everything but the diner waitress standing in the road watching us go, worriedly wiping her hands on her gingham apron.
那天晚上我们从9点到11点睡觉，后来我在一个完全不同的背景下才知道这叫“迪斯科午睡”。我们起床，喝了一些茶。女孩们给一些手帕喷了香水让我们戴在鼻子和嘴周围。我们就坐卡车出发去与反叛的鸡作战。场景应有尽有，除了那个站在路边看着我们远去、忧心忡忡地用格子围裙擦手的餐厅女服务员。
The chicken coop of the kibbutz was a one-storied structure of corrugated iron, about half the size of a football field. It emitted a low rumbling, a vague buzz that you could hear from far away. And of course from even farther away, there was the smell, a smell of such head-kicking intensity as to make a perfume-sprayed handkerchief almost adorable in its valiant naivete, Wile E. Coyote warding off a falling boulder with his paper parasol. And the combination of floral scent and dung merely increased the vileness.
基布兹的鸡舍是一个单层结构的波纹铁皮建筑，大约有半个足球场那么大。它发出一种低沉的隆隆声，一种从远处就能听到的模糊嗡嗡声。当然，从更远的地方还有那股味道，一股强度足以踢翻头的味道，让喷了香水的手帕在它勇敢的天真面前显得近乎可爱，就像威利狼（Wile E. Coyote）用纸遮阳伞抵挡坠落的巨石。花香和粪便的结合只会增加这种卑劣感。
Chicken [BLEEP] is horrible stuff. Unlike cow manure, which according to David Foster Wallace, smells "warm and herbal and blameless," chicken [BLEEP] is an olfactory insult, a snarling, saw-toothed, ammoniac, cheesy smell, needlessly, gratuitously disgusting, a stench of such assaultive tenacity that it burns your eyes. Rather than making you never want to eat a chicken again, it simply makes you angry. It makes you hold a grudge. You'll eat chicken again, by god, and you'll chew really, really hard.
鸡屎是可怕的东西。不同于大卫·福斯特·华莱士所说的“温暖、草本且无辜”的牛粪，鸡屎是一种嗅觉侮辱，一种咆哮的、锯齿状的、氨味的、干酪味的味道，毫无必要地、肆无忌惮地令人厌恶，一种具有极强攻击性的恶臭，足以灼伤你的眼睛。与其让你再也不想吃鸡，它只会让你生气。它会让你怀恨在心。天哪，你还是会吃鸡的，而且你会嚼得非常、非常用力。
One of the barrel-chested Israelis shows us what to do. Pick up four chickens in each hand. This is done by grabbing hold of the birds by one leg. "If the leg snaps," he says, "it doesn't matter, just to get four in each hand. B'seder?" he says. OK?
其中一个胸膛宽阔的以色列人向我们演示该怎么做。每只手抓四只鸡。这是通过抓住鸟的一条腿来完成的。“如果腿断了，”他说，“没关系，只要每只手抓四只就行。B'seder？”他说。OK？
He faces us, holding the requisite eight, four in each hand, living masses of writhing feathers. He looks like some German expressionist cheerleader, his pom-poms alive, convulsing, filthy. "Who will see their dreams fall away into the abyss and eventually succumb to the crushing sadness and meaninglessness of it all? We will. And what does that spell? Madness. Louder. I can't hear you."
他面对着我们，手里拿着八只，每只手四只，那是扭动的羽毛活体团块。他看起来像个德国表现主义啦啦队长，他的绒球在颤动、肮脏、抽搐。“谁会眼睁睁看着梦想跌入深渊，并最终屈服于这一切令人沮丧的虚无和无意义之中？我们会。那怎么拼？疯狂。大声点。我听不见你们的声音。”
He crams the chickens roughly into a blue plastic crate smeared with wet guano. "And you close the lid, and tchick tchack," he tells us, clapping his hands with "that's that" finality. Before I even try, I know that I will not be able to do this. It is midnight, and we will be here until dawn, or until the truck is piled to capacity with crated birds.
他粗暴地把鸡塞进一个沾满湿鸟粪的蓝色塑料箱里。“然后你关上盖子， tchick tchack，”他拍着手，用一种“就是这样”的决绝告诉我们。在我还没尝试之前，我就知道我做不到。现在是午夜，我们要在这里待到黎明，或者直到卡车装满箱子。
I walk out into the sea of chickens. I reach down and grab one, its leg a slightly thicker, segmented chopstick. I recoil and stand up. I take a fetid breath, regroup, and bend down with new resolve, grab the chicken by its body with both hands, thinking somehow that might be preferable. Although how I think I'm going to get eight of them this way, I'm not sure. Its ribs expand and contract under my fingers, a dirty, warm, live umbrella. I drop the bird as if it were boiling hot.
我走进鸡的海洋。我伸手抓起一只，它的腿是一根稍微粗一点的、分段的筷子。我退缩着站了起来。我深吸一口恶臭的空气，重组队伍，怀着新的决心弯下腰，用双手抓住鸡的身体，不知怎么想那样可能更好。虽然我不确定怎么用这种方式抓八只。它的肋骨在我的手指下扩张和收缩，像一把脏兮兮的、温暖的活雨伞。我像扔掉沸腾的东西一样扔掉了那只鸟。
I leave the coop and go out to the trucks. Hoisting myself up onto the flatbed, I start to help with the stacking of the full crates. I know that my unilateral decision to change my task is met with displeasure on the part of the men who run the coop, but I do not care. Their muttered comments are predicated on a direct poultry-penile relationship. I might as well have spurned the stag party whore or gone to the woodshop and fashioned myself a sign that said "fag." "Ma ito? What's the matter with him," the head of the work detail asks when he sees me on the truck.
我离开鸡舍，走到卡车旁。我把自己拉上平板车，开始帮忙堆放满载的箱子。我知道我单方面改变任务的决定引起了管理鸡舍的男人们的不满，但我不在乎。他们喃喃自语的评论基于一种直接的家禽与阴茎的关系。我可能还不如拒接了单身派对妓女，或者去木工车间给自己做了一个写着“同性恋”的牌子。“Ma ito？他怎么了？”当我出现在卡车上时，工作组负责人问道。
[SPEAKING HEBREW], he is answered, using the female pronoun when referring to me. "The lady doesn't like the chickens."
[希伯来语]，他得到了回答，在提到我时使用了女性代词。“那个女士不喜欢这些鸡。”
It would be years before I was referred to as "she" again, and then very rarely and only as a joke by friends. I turn around to look at the man, making it quite clear to him that I understand what they are saying. The man who called me "she" avoids my eyes and busies himself with straightening a pile of crates and tightening the tarpaulin on the side of the truck. "You're right," I tell him in Hebrew. "She doesn't like the chickens."
多年以后，我才再次被称为“她”，而且那时很少，只是朋友间的一个笑话。我转过身看着那个男人，让他清楚地知道我听懂了他们在说什么。那个称我为“她”的男人避开了我的目光，忙着整理一堆箱子，拉紧卡车侧面的防水布。“你说得对，”我用希伯来语告诉他。“她确实不喜欢这些鸡。”
Have you ever had one of those moments when you know that you are being visited by your own future? They come so rarely and with so little fanfare, those moments. They're not particularly photogenic. There's no breach in the clouds to reveal the shining city on a hill, no folk-dancing children outside your bus, no production values to speak of, just a glimpse of such quotidian, incontrovertible truth that after the initial shock at the supreme weirdness of it all, a kind of calm sets in. So this is to be my life.
你有过那种时刻吗，当你意识到你正在被你自己的未来拜访？那些时刻来得如此罕见且几乎没有任何盛况。它们并不特别上相。云层中没有裂缝来揭示山上的闪亮城市，你的巴士外没有跳民族舞的孩子，没有可谈论的制作价值，只有一种琐碎的、不容置疑的真理的一瞥，以至于在最初对这一切至高无上的怪异感到震惊之后，一种平静油然而生。这就是我未来的生活。
At that very moment, I saw that I would never live on a kibbutz. I would not lose my virginity that summer to any of the girls from the group. Indeed, I would not care to do so. I am grateful to that macho blowhard. He made me consciously realize what I had always known but been somehow unable to say to myself. He's right. I don't like chickens. I like men.
就在那一刻，我看到我永远不会住在基布兹。那个夏天我不会和小组里的任何女孩失去童贞。事实上，我也不想这样做。我很感谢那个大男子主义的吹牛大王。他让我有意识地意识到我一直知道但却无法对自己说出口的事。他是对的。我不喜欢鸡。我喜欢男人。
Now, I live in Manhattan, the un-kibbutz, where nobody would dream of touching a live chicken, where whatever spirit of collectivist altruism people might have had dried up long ago. At camp, when I was young, I and the other children of affluent professionals would gather under the trees every day to sing before going into lunch. One of the songs was always "The Internationale," the hymn of the proletariat. One summer, we were even taught to sing it with our left fists raised.
现在，我住在曼哈顿，那个反基布兹的地方，没有人会梦想触摸活鸡，那里的任何集体利他主义精神早已干涸。在营地时，我年轻的时候，我和其他富裕家庭的孩子每天在午饭前聚在树下唱歌。其中一首歌总是《国际歌》，无产阶级的赞歌。有一个夏天，我们甚至被教导要举起左拳唱它。
We were, none of us, by any stretch of the imagination, what could be described as prisoners of starvation, wretched of the earth, or enthralled slaves. Admittedly, they are all catchier metaphors and easier to scan than, "Arise, ye children of psychiatrists," but they had little to nothing to do with us personally. And yet, for those few moments when we were singing, those words seemed so true. How can I describe to you that 11-year-old's sense of purpose, that thrill of belonging to something larger, something outside of my own body, the sheer heart-stopping beauty of a world of justice and perfection rising on new foundations. And that one line, "We have been naught. We shall be all."
我们没有一个人，无论怎么想象，能被描述为饥寒交迫的囚徒、苦难的人间或被奴役的奴隶。诚然，它们都是比“起来，你们精神科医生的孩子们”更琅琅上口的隐喻，更容易扫描，但它们与我们个人几乎毫无关系。然而，在我们唱歌的那几分钟里，那些词看起来如此真实。我怎么能向你描述那个11岁孩子的目标感，那种属于比我自身身体更大的东西、在自身身体之外的东西的快感，那种世界上正义和完美在新的基础上建立的令人心跳停止的美。还有那句，“我们一无所有。我们将拥有一切。”
Naught. It spoke as much about my wish to be delivered from this pre-adolescent self-loathing as it did to any consciousness of liberating the masses. But it held such promise of what I might hope for that even now, as I write this, I can still call up that old fervor. It still makes my breath catch in my throat.
无。它既谈到了我希望从这种青春期前的自我厌恶中解脱出来的愿望，也谈到了任何解放大众的意识。但它拥有如此美好的承诺，以至于即使现在，当我写下这些时，我仍然能唤起那种旧的热情。它仍然让我的呼吸哽在喉咙里。
David Rakoff's a writer in New York.
大卫·拉科夫是纽约的一名作家。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from [? Emmie Takehara, ?] Sylvia Lemus, and [? Leah Pogatchnik. ?]
嗯，我们今天的节目是由艾莉丝·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和我自己制作的，南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）参与制作，特约编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。制作协助：[? Emmie Takehara, ?] 西尔维娅·莱姆斯（Sylvia Lemus）和 [? Leah Pogatchnik. ?]
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you would like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果您想购买本节目的录音带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是 [email protected] 。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who describes the experience of listening to our radio program this way.
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他这样描述收听我们广播节目的体验。
You really, I think, fall into a bit of an existential crisis. What the hell am I doing?
你真的，我想，陷入了某种存在危机。我到底在做什么？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。